[Music]
my name's Fiona May of in court
it's my lady I'm always too busy the law
can take over your life
we're coming to bed hmm it's tomorrow
the case okay
my lady they're ready for you what's
right fee shall we talk excuse me
long day I don't know how to say this I
think I think I want to have an affair
what I love you
well then to be together but we don't
even kiss anymore yeah we have an urgent
case m'lady the applicant Adam has
leukemia
however the boy and his parents are
Jehovah's Witnesses and it's contrary to
their faith to accept blood into their
sister I would like to hear from Adam
himself you've come to change my mind
why is a blood transfusion wrong why is
anything wrong torture dying being
unfaithful in your marriage what is the
point of your silence
people think you've been influenced by
your parents somehow I've got to decide
the child's welfare shall be the courts
paramount consideration life is more
precious and dignity do you remember how
we were don't you miss that
[Music]
my lady I've got so many questions for
you thank you for coming my delicious
adventure see talk to me this young man
I thought I could transfer his questions
but he's dying
it's just a child lovely boy
[Music]
remember all of life and love
was a day of anguish at the world course
of justice
my lady they're ready for you
[Music]